if you're a kiwi you're probably tired
of hearing about
sheep lord of the rings and people
asking you where your country is
you're probably also tired of people
hearing your accent and asking
where are you from australia while the
english spoken in new zealand does
share a lot of features with australian
english it's a distinct variety of
english that has its own unique features
as well
between 1788 and 1841 new zealand was
loosely part of the colony of new south
wales which later became part of
australia
the earliest european settlers in new
zealand were traders and whalers from
new south wales who set up trading
stations
they were followed by missionaries from
england beginning in 1814.
the colony of new zealand was declared
as a separate entity in 1841
and britain began to carry out a process
of planned settlement
most migrants came from england wales
scotland and ireland
but many did not come directly a
significant number arrived from
australia
so some of them likely brought their
children who had been born in australia
this could have had an effect on the way
other children in the colony spoke and
influenced the emerging new zealand
accent
according to the census of 1871 the vast
majority of migrants were from britain
and ireland
but an inordinate number were scottish
or irish 27.3 percent and 22
respectively these particular
percentages could have also had an
influence on the emerging accent
new zealand english resembles australian
english more than any other variety
which may be a result of that early
australian settlement
a somewhat similar mix of migrant
accents and continuous contact between
new zealand and australia ever since
those days
the kiwi accent not all kiwi accents are
the same
there are basically two accents a
cultivated accent
which more closely resembles british
received pronunciation
and a broad accent which includes more
distinctly kiwi features
but a spectrum of accents exists in
between the two with those somewhere in
the middle range being considered
general new zealand english as is
typical in england and australia
accents of new zealand are generally
non-rhodic meaning that
r is not pronounced at the end of a
syllable but is rendered as a vowel
for example i say beer but kiwis say
b the main thing that distinguishes the
english of new zealand from australian
english and other varieties
is its vowels some of them shifted
during the 20th century
and these changes are more pronounced in
broad accents
most strikingly the original short front
vowels shifted
these changes lead to some interesting
contrasts listen to these examples in my
accent and the new zealand accent
chat chat mess miss
sit sit the shift in kiwi vowels was a
chain
shift meaning the first vowel began to
sound like the second one
and the second one began to sound like
the third one this might result in a
misunderstanding if you aren't aware of
the shift
sex sex sex seeks
six sucks please be mindful of this when
a kiwi is talking about christmas sacks
or playing the sacks
i find that when listening to kiwis with
a particularly broad accent i have to
sort of
translate the vowels in my head to make
sure that i'm understanding the right
word
aussies love to make fun of the third
vowel shift accusing kiwis of saying
fashion chops in aussie english that
same vowel has actually shifted slightly
in the opposite direction
so kiwis love to accuse aussies of
saying fish and chips
of course both pronunciations are
exaggerated before i mention the shift
from
a to e but it's worth pointing out that
kiwi english
underwent the trap bath split like
british and australian english but
unlike north american english
the trap bath split means that the early
modern english vowel
a became long ah in received
pronunciation
and long ah in new zealand pronunciation
before these specific consonants before
other consonants
it's a in received pronunciation and e
in new zealand so if you're a speaker of
north american english
some of the words that you pronounce
with an a will have
e in kiwi english but others will have
ah
another more recent shift in kiwi vowels
is that the vowels in near
and square are pronounced the same by
some speakers
near near square square
it's not fair it's not fair another
thing you might hear in kiwi english is
that past participles like grown
and known are sometimes pronounced as
growin
and knowin with a vowel inserted that
probably developed by analogy with other
past participles like
written or spoken which have a vowel in
that position this pronunciation is used
by around 50
of new zealanders while there are
different kiwi accents based on social
and economic factors
for the most part there aren't regional
variations an
exception is the regional accent of
southland and part of neighboring otago
where more than half of the original
settlers were from scotland
one characteristic of this accent is the
alveolar trill
or rolling r sound which occurs after
vowels
these days in particular after words
with the vowel in
nurse this is a feature that once faded
and became less common
but then rebounded and started to become
more common again
there's also a slightly different accent
that is specific to some kiwis of maori
background
it's particularly broad in its vowels
it's sometimes rhodic like the southland
accent
the t sound is sometimes unaspirated and
voiced
z is often devoiced to su at the end of
words
something that appears in kiwi english
in general but more often in maori
english
is the high rising terminal something i
talked about in my video on australian
english as well
high rising terminal occurs when the
speaker ends a statement with
rising intonation like a yes or no
question for example
during the holidays i like to get out of
town go to the mountains do some
tramping
or go to the batch with my mates that
sort of thing this is done to sort of
touch base with the listener while
you're speaking to check that they're
following what you're saying
another thing which was originally known
as a feature of maori speech but is now
used by new zealanders in general is
using
a at the end of a sentence to signal
that they want to check if the statement
is correct or to elicit a response
for example it's hot today aye it's
similar to the way canadians say a
but canadians these days don't say a as
often as they used to
kiwis now take the crown okay we're sort
of moving beyond the realm of accent now
so let's move on to
kiwi vocabulary and expressions a lot of
the casual words and expressions used in
new zealand are also used in australia
and
in some cases in the uk or ireland where
they originated
heaps this means a lot it's also used in
australia and the uk
of course this word exists in north
american english as well meaning
piles but it's not often used with the
meaning of a lot there were heaps of
people at the beach
gutted this means disappointed this is
also used in the uk and australia
the shops out of marmite yeah bro i'm
gutted
sweet ass this is another expression
meaning great or awesome
this phrase is an abbreviation of a
comparative phrase like
sweet as hell or something like that
this is very common in new zealand and
australia
and can be used with lots of different
adjectives it's hot as
naked buggered these words mean tired or
exhausted
this is originally slang from the uk
that's now used both in new zealand and
australia i'm pretty naked
it's worth noting that bugger is similar
to the f-word though not quite as taboo
it can also be used in some other
contexts where you might hear the f-word
too
for example bagarool like its f-word
equivalent it means nothing or none
what did you do over the holidays
bagarool
choca chocka block this means fall
do you want anything else to eat nah i'm
choker
this means swimsuit this is used in new
zealand australia and
ireland it's probably a result of irish
influence on kiwi and australian english
a cracker of a day this means a
beautiful day or a great day
the pattern of a cracker of a something
can be used with nouns in general to say
that something's great
it's a cracker of a song looks a bit sus
this means that someone or something
looks a bit suspicious
sus is used in other varieties of
english too but in different expressions
and contexts
mei like in australia this word means
friend
but can also be confrontational
depending on the context
bro this word too can be either friendly
or confrontational
i've been told that mate is used more by
non-maori while bro
is used more by maori in fact maori
english is sometimes referred to as
bro english so there's a lot of
crossover between kiwi and
australian english but other words and
expressions are uniquely kiwi
choice this means great or awesome the
whops
the whop-whops this means the middle of
nowhere
chile bin this means a portable cooler
jandles this means rubber sandals
apparently this is a contraction of the
phrase
japanese sandals bench this word refers
to a holiday home and is used in most of
new zealand on the north island
and the north half of the south island
crib this is the word for a holiday home
that's used on the southern half of the
south island
if your batch is out in the waps you
might do some tramping
which means hiking and while you're
tramping you might run into a
captain cooka which is a wild boar this
comes from the name of captain cook
he was the first person who released
pigs into the wild in new zealand
a different type of wild pig you might
encounter is kunekune
kunai is a maori word meaning plump and
if it's cold outside
i hope you bring us one dry which refers
to a heavy woolen shirt
this is actually the name of a new
zealand-based company that makes that
kind of shirt
but the brand name has become a
ubiquitous word for this type of product
and while you're on holiday i hope you
feel a box of birds
which means be in a good mood i hear
this is sometimes used in australia as
well but much less often
when you're not feeling a box of birds
be careful not to
pekka said which means be upset or throw
a tantrum that kid is pecking is sad
yeah he's a howly bag hallie bag this
means
whiner or crybaby a crack up
this means something or someone funny
that guy's a crack up
in my variety of english we use crack up
but as a verb
not a noun good as gold this means doing
very well
so how's life good is gold pakarood
this word means broken it comes from the
maori word pakaru
loanwords from maori are definitely one
of the most notable elements of the
english of new zealand
some maori words are optionally used
instead of an english equivalent
for example maori greetings are quite
widely used like
kyora which means hello or thank you but
literally
be healthy this is the maori word for
canoe
kiwi this word comes from maori and
refers to the kiwi bird
but you probably also know it as the
name of a fruit and the nickname for new
zealanders
this word refers to new zealanders of
european descent
but can also be extended to non-maori
new zealanders in general
it's not only maoris who use this word
by the way
this means treasure mana
this means a person or organization of
great prestige
it comes from the maori word mana
meaning prestige authority
or its source spiritual power hui
this means meeting we're holding a hui
tomorrow morning
in some cases words or phrases combine
both english and maori
half pi this means substandard or
unfinished pai
is the maori word for good couch kumura
this means couch potato kumara means
sweet potato in maori
by the way if you're interested in a
closer look at the maori language check
out my previous video on maori right
here
just like aussies kiwis make frequent
use of hypocharistics
in other words diminutive forms that
show affinity for someone or something
these usually consist of one syllable
from the base word
followed by a vowel suffix like e or o
some are the same as in australia while
others are specific to new zealand
a forklift driver four key good good o
smoko this means break time or a short
break
i guess it originally meant a smoke
break registration becomes
rejo compensation compose
names are often treated this way too
deborah becomes
dibs sharon becomes cesar sometimes
rhodic sounds turn into
z sounds it happens with place names too
queensland queenie auckland oaks
taranaki people often make up new ones
on the spot
just to play with words lighten a
conversation or whatever
as you can see the english of new
zealand is a special and unique variety
of english
in particular because of its
characteristic pronunciation
we also saw a lot of similarities with
australian english
but even in those cases when casual
words and expressions were the same
the new zealand accent was fairly
distinct i guess that's a result of
living so far from most other places
that people can't find you on the map
the question of the day for kiwis are
there any other features of your variety
of english that you want us to know
about
and to other people what's your favorite
kiwi word or expression that you heard
in this video
write your answers in the comments down
below as always i would like to give a
special thanks to the langfocus patreon
supporters especially the ones right
here on the screen who are the top tier
patreon supporters
patreon supporters help keep this
channel going month after month and
there are also some special bonus
benefits of becoming a patron
to see what it's all about check out
patreon.com
langfocus thank you for watching and
have a nice day
[Music]
you